let's go to southcat from virginia
southcat you're on the air
uh hello david uh
uh thanks for taking my call i actually
popped on to listen but um yeah i will
ask you
i'll bring something up that's been on
my mind
and by the way are you are you
originally from virginia
no i'm i'm actually from australia oh
okay that makes sense
so
uh
yeah um
something came up in my mind recently
was
how much it actually cost to have a
child in the u.s um whether you're
insured or not insured or anything like
that and if you're not insured
and this is a basic right to have a
child
you know um
and i think
there's a very few opportunities to have
a childhood free this is reproduction
um i'm not sure if you know anything
more about that but then you've also got
the issue of the abortion
issue that's going on um and i find i've
just really found it quite shocking that
it can cost it i mean if you've got a
private room you've got the money so it
all comes down to money
is that anything you've thought about
yeah i mean it's it's this way with a
lot of different things and depending on
you know what you consider a right you
would focus in on different aspects when
i had my random appendectomy i believe
the sticker price was forty thousand
dollars i was at the hospital in total i
think about
uh
eight hours i think and it was you know
about 40 grand from what i've read
the sticker price on on most
deliveries can approach a hundred
thousand dollars and if there's
complications you know you could be
talking about half a million every day
in the in the nicu is just outrageous
yeah i mean this is a bigger problem
it's a systemic problem that relates to
the health care system but you're a
hundred percent correct
yeah i just think
i mean i don't understand that there's
huge problems with the health care
system but
having a baby
you know
uh is
it's it's just
struck me as crazy yeah it costs i mean
at least maybe they could
i mean listen it's crazy but there's a
lot of other equally crazy things in the
united states so i don't disagree with
you it's just you know i'm sort of used
to it i guess
yeah i i i guess so yeah um anyway
thanks for taking my call all right
southcat from virginia originally
from australia folks i think we did it
despite the two dropped calls one of the
best
series of calls ever on the show we will
take a break and be back with much much
more after this